aujourd'hui s'il coûte 28 août
vous avez rendez vous avec les
programmes dans cinq minutes ça a donné
quoi les audiences
j'aurai besoin de vous parler
demandez pas les choses
obtenez les la dictature par la peur ça
marche plus le team parce que c'est
mieux ailleurs personnes mortes hier je
vous aime bien antoine
j'aimerais pas que vous exploser en
plein vol c'est pas un roman sa personne
s'intéresse à toi leurs titulaires ce
taux de taille sur moi que tu prends le
talent profil d'un héros ce que tu fais
quand les gens sont poussés à bout
faut pas s'étonner qu'ils pètent les
plombs
[Applaudissements]
c'est un survivant toi ta crise
cardiaque doit te permettre de réaliser
ce qui est vraiment important
je n'ai pas fait de crise cardiaque
on m'a tiré dessus pourquoi vous les
escalader la mairie du domicile de son
jasper qu'est ce que ces chemins vous
êtes qui et vous non chez vous ces 73
boulevard pasteur
[Musique]
personne nouveau à thierry tu es ça
c'est quoi
vous aider mais ce que tu fais dans mon
bureau police
je comprends pas ce qui m'arrive
pourquoi est-ce que tout a changé
l'impression est devenu fou
maintenant
thür accepte aussi il faut mais c'est
tranquille maintenant à la rentrée chez
solange arrive [ __ ] merde
[Musique]
en train de couler antoine
tu rentres et ronde avec toi et toi tu
pourras pas
cet outil piste rdr
tu mérite pas ce qui m'arrive
[Musique]
les choses obtenez
konecny pu nous fait trop strict